bom dia a todos
uma coisa que eu nunca entendi é porque
é proibido passar cola na escola
alguém já perguntou isso que acontece
com uma criança que passa cola na escola
ela é castigada é punida tomazela vai
para a diretoria mas para mim a cola é a
colaboração é ajudar quem sabe menos do
que eu eu eu pedi ajuda para quem sabe
mais do que eu
quando uma criança não sabe responder
uma questão da prova quando ela não está
preparada para a prova
não é porque é vagabundo porque ela não
estudou direito ela tem dificuldade de
entender aquela matéria mas já tem
dificuldade de entender aquilo que está
sendo ensinado
então ela tem problemas em casa também
os seus pais estejam se você não tem
alguma coisa acontecendo que está
atrapalhando o desempenho dela ea gente
trata as pessoas como pessoas que não
estão se esforçando o suficiente a gente
começasse estimular as pessoas a
passarem cola de repente
talvez a nossa relação com a sociedade
mudasse e vou dar um exemplo
a criança começou na escola ela tem
dificuldade ela não pode pedir ajuda
para ninguém e ela sofre de uma outra
pessoa que sabe aquilo que ela não sabe
fazer não só ajudar e ela não pode
ajudar e passam se os anos ela está
sempre competindo com aquela pessoa e
deixou garantir o meu desejo é me
preparar deixa eu fazer meu trabalho de
estudar já garantia a minha nota se você
foi mal e prometeu paciência você vai lá
você tem que se esforçar mais a próxima
vez mas eu garanti a minha parte metrô
crescia e passam se os anos em que está
o tempo inteiro nesse modelo de educação
e você chega no vestibular que acontece
o vestibular competição mais uma vez o
processo seletivo para ver quem consegue
a melhor vaga na faculdade
a gente está o tempo inteiro competindo
um com o outro então eu fui lá estudei
me esforcei passei no vestibular
conseguir se você não conseguiu
paciência você vai fazer cursinho
você vai se esforçar mais uma vez mas eu
conseguir meritocracia entrou lá na
faculdade com os meus amigos eu quero
começar a trabalhar e vou entrar no
mercado de trabalho que acontece no
mercado de trabalho processo seletivo
mais uma vez então o processo seletivo
eu competindo com os meus colegas para
ver quem consegue emprego quem consegue
aquele estágio é eu fui lá eu consegui
um estágio fico feliz da vida comemora
comemora como inclusive os amigos
programa
a família e se você não conseguiu
paciência você vai se esforçar mais vai
se preparar mais vai fazer cursos vai se
vestir melhor vai fazer alguma coisa que
te permita conquistar aquela vaga que
você quer você trabalhando lá com seus
colegas de trabalho e você que aquela
vaga de supervisor de coordenador de
gerente e diretor de presidente e não
tem pra todo mundo está sempre
competindo um com o outro e te passar a
vida inteira fazendo essa competição
competindo um com o outro um contra o
outro alcance desse modelo fala não
quero mais moderno do mundo corporativo
ou empreender e quando vou entender que
acontece eu vou competir mais uma vez
são os meus concorrentes
eu vou competir por um investidor com
outros empreendedores pelo investimento
de um investidor
eu vou competir com concorrentes que não
quero nem olhar na cara porque somos
concorrentes fazem a mesma coisa que
estão disputando o mesmo mercado
e nessa lógica a gente cria uma
sociedade que se separou uma sociedade
que se diz conector e que não sabe
ajudar o outro e eu seguir esse caminho
minha vida toda então eu fui educado foi
preparado para seguir esse caminho para
fazer meu caminho da escola para estudar
bastante para conseguir entrar num bom
passar no vestibular em uma boa
faculdade entrei numa boa faculdade de
administração e depois eu queria
trabalhar numa multinacional passei por
um processo seletivo entrei como
estagiário em uma multinacional
americana comecei a trabalhar
comecei a crescer na carreira tive
algumas promoções aí eu vi que não
queria mais aquilo que ele não fazia
muito sentido que tinha alguma coisa no
mundo corporativo que não fazia sentido
para mim não teria que me disse que era
de verdade eu tinha que seguir algumas
regras eu tinha que seguir o que mandava
fazer e eu não tinha voz nenhuma não
tinha possibilidade de criar nada eu
decidi que não queria mais aquilo que
alguns anos atrás eles de querer sair
pedir demissão do mundo corporativo e
comecei a aprender
só quando eu comecei a aprender eu vi
que eu não sabia absolutamente nada de
empreendedorismo
eu vim aqui no o fato de eu ser um bom
funcionário mundo corporativo não me
credenciava ser um empreendedor e eu
comecei a bater cabeça comecei a tentar
me virar sozinho aprender as coisas que
eu não tinha aprendido na faculdade de
administração aprender as coisas que
nunca me ensinaram a vida para conseguir
triunfar no empreendedorismo e eu sei o
quanto é difícil porque eu sei quantos
anos eu batalhei para conseguir
conquistar as coisas que você comece a
empreender
quem é quem prende sabe que são muitas
coisas que têm que fazer
sem saber vender sem saber que o lado
financeiro tem que saber fazer marketing
digital você tem que cuidar de redes
sociais você tem que fazer é instalar
condicionadas tem que ligar pra
consertar internet sem comprar papel
higiênico sem fazer um monte de coisas
ao mesmo tempo e são pouquíssimas as
pessoas que conseguem fazer isso é por
isso que tanta gente tem dificuldade de
empreendedorismo e sai de cima do do
mundo corporativo
fui pro mundo do empreendedorismo eu
passei pra esses dois lugares e eu falei
bom será que é só isso que existe então
será que são esses dois mundos ou eu vou
ser um funcionário do mundo corporativo
onde não vou poder ter voz onde não vou
poder criar as minhas ideias onde não
vou poder fazer nada ou apenas seguir o
que me mandam fazer esse é um cargo
o rótulo ou será que eu vou ter que sair
para empreender e aí você é muito
difícil tem que fazer tantas coisas têm
que desenvolver tanto as habilidades tem
que superar tantas adversidades tantos
obstáculos para conseguir triunfar
depois de alguns negócios empreendendo
eu comecei a acreditar que talvez
existisse um terceiro caminho um outro
modelo o caminho do meio onde pudessem
prender não sozinho tendo toda a
responsabilidade
tenho que tomar todas as decisões e
tendo que assumir nas minhas costas o
peso de ter uma empresa de onde parece
dividir isso com outras pessoas com
pessoas que me complementassem com
pessoas que fosse melhor do que eu em
outras em algumas áreas pessoas que
soubessem fazer aquilo que eu não sei
fazer
alguns meses atrás eu decidi lançar um
empreendimento no modelo completamente
diferente
o modelo que chama de empresa livre uma
empresa livre uma empresa de todo mundo
é igual
hoje todo mundo é sócio onde todos têm a
mesma participação de cada um é livre
para escolher como vai se envolver cada
um é livre como vai trabalhar aí pra
escolher onde vai trabalhar quantas
horas por dia vai trabalhar em
quantidade com o projeto vai se
relacionar
nesse movimento eu comecei a ver que
estava testando o modelo novo se
juntando pela complementaridade
eu me junto a pessoas que sabem fazer
aquilo que eu não sei fazer tão bem ea
gente junto vai conseguir criar muito
mais
e se cada um tiver autonomia e liberdade
para trabalhar da forma como gostaria de
trabalhar com alto potencial de criação
é muito maior
só que acontece quando vai criar um
modelo desse você volta naquela questão
de que a gente foi educado para viver de
um outro uma outra forma
um outro modelo o modelo de competição
então podemos falar de colaboração e
quando a gente fala de economia
colaborativa a gente encontra um
problema aí a gente não sabe colaborar
a gente nunca aprendeu a fazer isso a
gente nunca foi estimulado a colaborar
então como é que você chega e cria uma
empresa livre e falar que você quer
pessoas a partir de agora elas são
livres
elas passaram 20 e 30 anos vivendo a
vida de outra forma tendo que seguir
regra tem que decorar as coisas tendo
que provar para os outros
tenho que copiar o modelo de outra
pessoa você pegar um modelo acadêmico
você vai fazer o seu tcc você não pode
dar sua opinião sem citar uma pessoa
quando se faz um mestrado você não pode
dar sua opinião
você tem que citar uma outra pessoa e só
quando você for doutor aí sim você pode
dar sua opinião
esse mundo que a gente criou de pessoas
que não podem dar sua opinião e que não
podem se expressar
a gente não sabe se quem a gente é de
verdade acho que o desafio de uma
empresa livre é a gente conseguir
permitir às pessoas serem que a nação de
verdade cria uma estrutura para que cada
um possa ser quem é de verdade
só que a gente não sabe quem a gente é
que a gente nunca foi instigado a ser
que a gente é verdade a gente foi sempre
estimulada ser uma outra pessoa
a gente sempre estimulado a ce que a
sociedade gostaria que a gente fosse os
nossos pais gostariam que a gente fosse
os nossos amigos gostaria que a gente
fosse a gente passa vários anos havia
tentado seguir com as pessoas que a
gente tem que fazer que quando fala pra
gente que pode ser que a gente é gente
entra em parafuso
a gente não sabe eu queria compartilhar
alguns insights que o que a gente tem
tido nesta jornada rumo ao desconhecido
que é criar uma empresa livre foi preso
no outro modelo
são vários paradigmas que a gente tem
que desconstruir você chega para
trabalhar no modelo totalmente
horizontal onde ninguém é chefe de
ninguém onde ninguém melhor do que
ninguém
a gente não sabe muito bem como fazer
isso quente
algumas pessoas têm um ego muito inflado
e já chegou querendo mandar quem assume
a posição de líder e outras pessoas
chegam e elas foram a vida inteira
educadas para serem funcionários que
elas não sabem como elas podem ter
autonomia mas podem ter suas próprias
idéias
a gente vai criar esse desequilíbrio a
gente não sabe muito bem como fazer isso
1 começa a entrar no papel do outro e
começa a entrar em conflito
a gente não sabe como lidar com o
conflito a gente aprendeu a fugir do
conflito a vida toda a gente não quer
discutir não quer brigar não quer
resolver os problemas a gente quer fugir
dos problemas
a gente não quer olhar para eles mas
numa organização horizontal onde todo
mundo é igual
se não tiver essa resolução de conflitos
se você não tiver disposição que olhar
para outra pessoa de conversar sobre os
problemas e de olhar para suas próprias
sombras para poder resolver essas coisas
que você tem dentro de você
isso não vai funcionar isso não vai dar
certo só que uma empresa não tem uma
estrutura para apoiar essa transformação
é uma jornada de transformação quando
você vai empreender no modelo diferente
você vai fazer uma coisa que nunca
ninguém fez antes e por isso é muito
importante a gente criar redes de apoio
é por que é tão importante dentro desse
grupo existe o cuidado mútuo disso um
olhar mais solidário para o outro a
gente olhar para o outro como alguém que
está no mesmo barco que a gente e que é
a mesma coisa e não como um concorrente
não como um competidor espaço onde a
gente pode mostrar a vulnerabilidade
vulnerabilidade é outra coisa que a
gente não aprendeu a fazer na vida a
gente aprendeu a ser forte
a gente aprendeu a mostrar com bom a
gente é gente aprendeu a valorizar
nossas forças de esconder as nossas
fraquezas
só que na verdade quando a gente se
vulnerabiliza a gente se conecta mães
quando a gente compartilha as nossas
dores as pessoas têm vontade de ajudar a
gente a gente começar a compartilhar as
nossas dores e criar um espaço aberto
para isso para que a gente possa falar
sobre as nossas dores porque posso falar
sobre o que incomoda a gente possa pedir
ajuda porque aí sim a gente vai se
conectar
aí sim a gente vai conseguir se ajudar
enquanto a gente tiver investir nas
nossas máscaras de seres humanos
perfeitas de pessoas fora de grandes
empreendedores e pessoas visionárias
incríveis e que sabem realizar
ninguém vai querer ajudar a gente a
gente baixar a guarda e pede ajuda a
gente consegue as pessoas que está no
nosso dna
talvez a gente não tenha aprendido na
vida a colaborar
vontade de ajudar desde que a gente
nasceu se você vê uma pessoa chorando
você quer ajudar essa pessoa você tem
uma pessoa que se você quer dar um
abraço nessa pessoa
a gente tem que trazer esse olhar para
as empresas também as empresas não são
esse espaço da vida com competitiva onde
você não pode se expressar onde você não
pode mostrar quem você é de verdade
a gente passa a maior parte da nossa
vida dentro das empresas no trabalho
vocês não criar novas estruturas para
isso vai criar vai continuar sofrendo um
modelo que não deixa a gente satisfeito
só para criar esse modelo é preciso
inovar é preciso usar e que a inovação a
gente nem sabe direito quem não gosta de
falar muito de nossa gente nem sabe de
inovação
se você conseguir ser quem você é de
verdade você já vai estar inovando
porque nunca na história do planeta
terra veio ninguém que chegou a você
você consegue ser você mesmo você já vai
estar inovando e você consegue criar um
grupo de pessoas que são elas mesmas
aí esse grupo é promover uma revolução
porque são um grupo de pessoas que vão
sair não vão ainda mais
acho que a gente tenta fazer quando a
gente cria um modelo é criar um espaço
para que cada um possa ser quem é de
verdade que a pessoa não seja apenas um
rótulo que não seja apenas um cargo para
que ela seja quem ela é de verdade pra
que ela possa fazer aquilo que ela tem
vontade de fazer o que ela consegue se
expressar a partir dos seus talentos a
partir das suas vontades a partir dos
seus dons
se a gente conseguir criar um espaço
para isso o potencial de criação de uma
empresa vai ser absolutamente incrível a
gente vai conseguir criar muito mais a
gente vai conseguir tornar muito mais o
potencial de criação porque vai usar
tudo que a gente sabe fazer o desafio
quando você cria um modelo novo é juntar
um pouco de tudo isso um pouco dessa
nessa esse aprendizado de como é
trabalhar com liberdade de como é
trabalhar de maneira horizontal de como
é criar o cuidado mútuo de como é criar
modelos jurídicos novos que permitam
isso de como criar um modelo baseado na
confiança de como dividir o dinheiro de
uma forma mais justa e mais solidária e
como se não bastasse tudo isso tem que
fazer um negócio dá certa
e dá resultado financeiro e gerar
dinheiro
é um desafio muito grande quando se fala
de colaboração a colaboração não tem que
acontecer só entre o grupo de pessoas
que está envolvido no projeto
a operação tem que ser todo o mundo
todo mundo tem que apoiar todo mundo o
desafio que a gente tem é conseguir
abrir para que mais pessoas possam
participar porque esse modelo como esse
que a gente chama de empresa livre poder
funcionar e conseguir retorno financeiro
para muita gente consegui permitir que
as pessoas sejam quem relação de verdade
a gente vai gerar um benefício para a
humanidade está gerando benefício para
pessoas que querem sair do sistema e não
sabem como as pessoas que estão aqui no
mundo corporativo e não tem coragem ou
não tem condições ou não tempo algum
motivo não podem sair daquilo para
empreender no modelo que vai ser muito
difícil
o modelo onde ela vai estar sozinha ou
com um ou dois sócios tentando criar
aquela empresa dos sonhos dela ela
existe um meio termo um caminho do meio
onde a gente possa junto onde posso
ajudar a gente possa criar uma empresa
maior do que aquela empresa que a gente
conseguiria sustentar com o dinheiro que
a gente fatura da empresa que a gente
conseguisse todo mundo usar suas
habilidades para criar alguma coisa
maior
o que eu acredito de verdade que está
acontecendo no mundo está vivendo um
período de transição
a gente tá saindo de um sistema que não
funciona mais
indo para um sistema que ainda não
existe
nosso modelo de emprego não funciona
mais quantas pessoas estão em depressão
no trabalho
o nosso tema político não funciona mais
nem falar muito sobre isso
os nossos sistemas de educação não
funciona mais o sistema da religião não
funciona mais o sistema de saúde não
funciona mais
a gente está começando a perceber que
isso não funciona mais
a gente não quer mas isso a gente quer
outra coisa só que essa outra coisa não
apareceu e porque está todo mundo
perdido aqui nesse meio do caminho
nesse meio termo esta é justamente nessa
transição
só que essa mudança já está acontecendo
quer a gente queira quer não o mundo já
está mudando mas já estão saindo desse
sistema antigo
um sistema que a gente não existe não
viu ainda aparecer ea gente está aqui
vai criar a gente tem a possibilidade de
criar um modelo novo de criar um novo
sistema e não apenas uma nova empresa
inovadora mas um sistema novo
a gente se permite explorar essas nossas
potencialidades
se a gente olhar com um olhar diferente
para essa crise que está acontecendo a
gente vai ver que no caos que a gente
consegue transformar as coisas nas
cadeias de comando e controle isso não é
possível acontecer mas no caos
a gente consegue criar coisas novas tem
que aproveitar esse momento de transição
após viver dessa forma acho que o mundo
já está mudando a gente pode escolher a
gente vai querer resistir a ele e sofrer
e querer segurar as coisas do jeito como
ela são o city vai querer participar da
construção de um novo mundo
eu escolhi participar
eu acho que a vida fica muito mais legal
quando você consegue participar de uma
coisa nova
a vida tem mais graça e não construir um
mundo novo para que daqui 50 anos ele
seja diferente porque daqui 50 anos
nossos filhos vivem num mundo diferente
não é deste mundo novo aconteça hoje
porque a minha vida seja boa hoje
por que não agora eu consiga ser feliz e
não que o trabalho para que daqui 50
anos eu seja feliz mas que hoje eu
consiga criar aquele mundo que eu quero
ver eles que acredita que a gente hoje
conseguiria juntar as nossas forças mas
poderia criar um espaço que a gente
possa ser quem é de verdade porque é aí
que está a graça na vida a gente pode
ser que a gente é verdade é muito mais
fácil você ser quem você é o que você
veste marcas dá muito mais trabalho este
máscaras
dá muito trabalho sei quem você não é
quando você consegue ser quem você é de
verdade ea vida fica mais legal isso se
puder ser quem você é de verdade com
outras pessoas que também são que a
nação de verdade você consegue mudar
muita coisa esse convite que eu faço pra
vocês mas vocês olham pra vida de vocês
dessa forma para que eles consigam criar
espaço para que vocês possam ser quem
você é de verdade no trabalho junto com
pessoas que acreditam na mesma coisa que
você caminha é uma das chaves é você se
juntar com pessoas que acreditam na
mesma coisa que você se você puder se
juntar essas pessoas e criar um modelo
novo vocês vão poder tirar suas idéias
do papel e fazer os sonhos acontecerem e
nem se acredita que a gente veio aqui
para realizar o sonho a gente tem a
gente vem aqui pra fazer aquilo que a
gente tem vontade de fazer a gente vê
aqui para viver hoje o mundo que a gente
tem vontade de viver
obrigado